We'd love to hear your thoughts on the dichotomy of honest self expression
versus normal face and or passion versus discipline.
Uh,
if you aren't caught up on all the podcasts,
normal faces game.
I used to play with my kids where they would have to keep an expressionless face
or what I call the normal face,
good game by the way.
And you,
I would line up my kids and they would have to keep that face and then if they
change their expression anyway,
I would hit them in the head with a,
with the inside cardboard role of a thing of wrapping paper.
And,
or I had eventually made like foam pieces for it because they were a little bit
more durable and,
and you could hit really hard and it wouldn't hurt at all.
So anyways,
I know it sounds like you should call child services on me,
but it's fun game to play because as you hit one kid that makes the other kids
laugh and then you ended up hitting them all and everyone's laughing and it's
fun.
So,
and there's also a pragmatic reason to do it because it teaches people to
control their emotions and there are times,
there are many times where you have to learn to control your emotions and as
kids,
if you learn to control your emotions,
it's going to be beneficial for you in many ways.
What does that mean that you should keep a normal face all the time?
Never show emotions.
No,
it's not like that at all.
There's like everything else.
There's a dichotomy that you have to balance.
If your kid wins a wrestling match,
you should be happy and great and smiling.
Yeah,
I five right.
That's cool.
If you bite
into a amazing piece of prime rib that your wife cooked for you,
then you should raise your fist to the air and say,
yes,
my wife,
the first time she ever cooked primary,
she,
we didn't know this,
but she has a talent.
She knows she cooks dry chicken prime ribs.
She knocks it out of the park.
First time she ever cooked prime rib and I took my,
I smelled amazing.
I was like,
Oh,
this is,
I took my first bite.
I looked at her and I looked up at her and I said,
I want to revamp,
redo our vows from marriage,
renew,
renew the vows.
So yes,
um,
you know,
scenarios like that.
Yeah.
You want to show your emotions and if here's something,
if your team slacks off
and if you fail the mission,
you fail the task.
Of course you're going to own it.
But you might,
you know,
you might want to show a little anger about what happened so that everyone knows
like,
oh,
who's chocolate doesn't normally get mad and he's mad.
And so we really did something bad.
And you know,
even though you're blaming herself,
like I can't believe,
I'd like to doubt.
You know what I mean?
Like you show a little bit that people go,
okay,
yeah.
So there you're going to show you,
most of you,
if you get bad and we'll,
if you get news that,
that,
you know,
you've got a friend that died,
we knew that you've got to let those emotions out.
There's all kinds of situations where emotions are not only acceptable,
but they're needed and they're required.
And in fact,
if you don't have emotions in those situations,
that's horrible.
You need to have them not only as a person,
as a human being,
you need to let out your emotions sometimes.
But as a leader,
if you don't show any emotions at all,
no one's going to follow you.
There is no connection between you and the people on your team.
And if you ever,
if you just sit there and think about people that you've worked for that didn't
have show emotions,
you had no connection with them,
you don't care about them,
you'll leave.
You won't go the extra mile to get the job done.
So you have to show emotions.
But of course there are many times in life in the world where showing your
emotions are going to have a negative impact on your situation,
your you,
you give up the take down it.
You just do a competition and you show it in your face.
That person just thinks I just do right?
You don't show any emotion.
Their boss tells you you're getting stuck with the underperforming team.
Show any emotion,
right?
Don't,
don't.
Oh Man,
don't do that,
but hey,
what about this?
And there's a good one.
Boss is giving you feedback that you don't agree with.
Roll your eyes.
He's going,
I mean the the heavy side,
the clenched teeth as you're trying to listen with this person,
you don't even respect him.
He's telling us,
what's that gonna get you.
I'm not going to get you anything.
Then showing that negative emotion there,
you need to keep normal face in that situation.
Your kids doing something that's annoying.
It's trying to test your patience and they're just trying to piss you off.
Don't let them keep it in check.
Get told to go to the other line in DMV after you've been waiting for an hour
and one don't freak out.
Don't show any emotions.
Got It.
Here's,
here's another one.
We already talked about this one.
Your friends or poke in front of you because you missed a shot at the range or
you got lost on a land navigation course or whatever.
Get All mad.
Don't get frustrated.
Don't show any emotion.
You know,
they make fun of your hair cut.
They make fun of your accent.
They make fun of whatever.
Don't show emotions.
Don't freak out.
That's the other balance.
Now there are also times where you might have to force yourself to show some
emotion just to get the point across,
right?
Your kid hasn't listened to you after five or six violations.
You might have to show some anger or they or they do something that's going to
get him hurt,
right?
You got to show some emotion so that they realized that was real.
But flying off the temporary flying off the handle and losing your temper is
almost never does you any good.
So yeah,
you have to be balanced.
In order to be balanced,
you have to be in control.
In order to be in control,
you have to detach from your emotion so you can control your emotions and not
let your emotions
control you.
I think we already talked about this one part before it.
We're like,
you know,
like with your kids or whatever and you're,
you fly off the handle,
not fly off the handle,
but you,
you show emotion,
you raise your voice and yell at them because this one is important.
This lesson that I'm teaching,
you obviously didn't get it before,
it wasn't your thing.
He can do that every single time.
Of course,
every single lesson like,
okay,
Holy Hill is effective when it reads my voice.
Let me just raise my voice now.
Right.
Logically limb die if that,
if that is what induces their compliance,
let me just do that.
Right.
Doesn't work that way because after a while I like,
oh talk,
just don't noise.
No.
So yeah,
you've got to be like Christ.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Or yeah,
just be like normal face,
north face,
everything you know.
And then like the one time you use it,
it's like the,
what do you call the,
there's this video game I used to play.
It's like you could just press the button and
blow up everybody.
Anyway,
long story,
but yeah,
don't use it all the time is what I'm saying.
Just use it like sparingly,
you're saying?
Yeah,
judiciously.
Cool.
That's a good ted.
Do know what you're saying?